simplify three times the square root of
200 X to the third so a good place to
start let's factor out 200 so if I'm
just focusing on the 200 here 202 times
100 and 100 is a perfect square it's 10
times 10 it is 10 times 10 and then if
we were to factor X to the third that's
the same thing as X 2 squared times X so
let's write that out so let me just
rewrite this whole thing is equal to 3
times the square root
I'll write it all under one big radical
sign right now of 2 times 100 times x
squared times X let me stretch the
radical sign so the x squared times X
that is X to the third and then the 200
the 200 is 2 times 100 now we can think
of this as all of these numbers the
product of all of these numbers to the
one-half power taking the square root of
the product that's like taking the
square root of or that's equivalent to
taking the square root of each of these
terms so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 3 times the
square root of 2 times the square root
of 100 square root of a hundred times
the square root of x squared times the
square root of x squared times the
square root of x times the square root
of x these terms right there in blue
that's these terms right there the terms
in orange that's those terms right over
there now several of these are not too
hard to evaluate so we have our 3 out
front so this is going to be equal to 3
and then let me mark off the terms let's
do this one first what's the square root
of 100 or the principal root of 100 the
positive square root well it's 10 10
times 10 is 100 this is going to be 3
times 10 that's that term right there
and then what is the square root of x
squared well it's just X X times X is x
squared so times X and then we have to
deal
so we've dealt with that we've dealt
with that we've dealt with that and then
we have these two terms right here where
they we can't take the square root so we
could say times the square root of 2
times the square root of x
so this term right here times the square
root of two and then finally out here
times the square root of x so if we want
to simplify this fully if we wanted to
simplify this fully we get 3 times 10
times X which is 30x and then we can
actually merge these this is to the
square root of 2 times the square root
of x that's the same thing as the square
root of 2x so we could say x times the
square root of 2x and we have simplified
this as far as it can go